- Let's welcome our
first guest, everybody.
You have seen her in
"Ant-Man: Quantumania,"
and you knew him from
"Riverdale," or you know him,
you knew him, you know him,
all the things, all the tenses,
and now you can see them together
in the movie "Lisa Frankenstein."
It's in Theaters Friday.
Please welcome Kathryn
Newton and Cole Sprouse.
(all cheering)
(upbeat music)
Oh my gosh.
- Not every day you do an
interview with a puppy.
- [Kelly] I'm just, you're welcome.
- Thank you, thank you, Kelly.
- I love, you love dogs, you have three?
- [Kathryn] I have three.
- Yeah?
- I have three poodles.
There's Jack King Ruler of All Fluff,
Danford Ladybird Keep the Madness Rolling,
and Starlight Rosebud Hella
Goodboy Gonna Need a Big Bank.
This is Frost.
- What?
- [Kathryn] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- And what's this one's name, Snowflake?
- This is Snowflake, I chose Snowflake
because she has the same bags
under her eyes that I do.
- [Kelly] You need sleep.
- I said, "You're just as
tired as me, Snowflake.
Let's do this thing."
- Oh my God, so cute.
So which dog is in this video, though?
We have video right here.
- [Kathryn] I think he just likes me.
- [Kelly] Which dog is this?
- That's Starlight Rosebud Hella Goodboy
Gonna Need a Big Bank, his name's Buddy.
He doubles as my caddy on the side.
He likes to chase birds,
and my other dog, Jack,
professional golfer, okay?
He doesn't go to the
bathroom on the golf course.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Pro,
and he will like fetch my golf ball
and bring it back to me
so I can just practice.
- That's nice.
- Yeah.
My big guy, he just chases everything.
He thinks he's a real dog.
- Do they usually allow,
I feel like I have golfed,
and I don't know that dogs were allowed
to come on the golf course.
- They're probably not, but I think
they just don't say anything.
- That's very, you know what,
you can always say sorry
later, do what you want.
There you go, that's the goal, yeah.
Wait, and here, Cole, this is you.
This is your Pomeranian, right?
- [Kathryn] Oh my God.
(audience laughing)
- Look at the closeup
on that, it's amazing.
What's your dog's name again?
- That's Bear or Goose.
- Bear or Goose, is it depending
on the day or?
- One of the two.
Unlike Kathryn's dogs,
I don't think he has an
ounce of dog left in him.
I think he is-
- [Kathryn] Bird?
- Yeah, he's a little bit more bird,
like Goose, like a big goose.
- Okay.
- "Bear and Goose," actually,
that's a book my son
loves to read, actually.
That's amazing.
This is kind of cool because sometimes
when you're in movies
you don't know people,
but y'all have been
friends for a while, right?
- Yeah, long time.
- Yeah, when did y'all meet?
- Well.
(Kathryn laughs)
- [Kelly] Do you have different stories?
- Kathryn revealed to me only a month ago.
- Oh, that's right, we
met a long time ago.
- That she asked for a
photo of my twin and I
at Bob's Big Boy in Los Angeles.
- I was around seven years old,
huge fan, obviously, who wasn't, right?
Everyone here is a fan.
(audience cheering)
And I'm lucky enough to be one
of the people who got a
picture with the Sprouse twins.
- I didn't remember the moment.
- No,
(audience laughs)
and I didn't tell him about it
until way, way into filming,
because I wanted to
like be cool, you know?
I wanted to be like we're both
actors, like we're the same.
We're not the same.
(all laughing)
- We are equal.
- We are not the same,
not at all.
- Well, you did a photo shoot with,
because I mean, he's a photographer.
We talked about this last
time, but you did a photo shoot
with him, and it kind
of was like inspiring
for this whole movie, right?
- Yeah.
You know, I've seen Cole multiple times
throughout the years.
We met again when he was on "Riverdale"
and I was on "Supernatural,"
and he kept talking
about my poodles 'cause
I have these crazy dogs,
and finally I asked you to just shoot,
and he shot it in my
house with these wigs,
and it was like you came
up with this narrative,
like a woman who killed all her husbands,
and is just collecting dogs
and diamonds, you know?
And I feel like it was a
precursor to our film, 'cause-
- Yeah, I gotta talk to my
therapist about that idea.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah,
there's a lot to dive in there.
- [Kathryn] Yeah.
- So explain "Lisa Frankenstein"
to somebody who has never seen it.
- Oh, did you hear that?
- He's a fan.
- Well, how would we explain this movie?
- I think it's a camp love letter to some
of that '80s film and television
that we were receiving.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It deals with grief,
and you get to build your own
boyfriend, which is awesome.
I won't say too much.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Cole] You know, I
can't say too much more.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kathryn] He basically got it.
- Yeah, you build your own boyfriend,
like Kelly LeBrock in "Weird Science."
- That's right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, very much like that.
- That's one of my favorite movies, yeah.
- It was a really fun,
weird movie to make,
and my costar doesn't speak,
so it was nice for me.
(audience laughing)
- It was my favorite
part of our friendship.
No, that is interesting, you
don't speak in it, right?
- [Cole] I don't.
- So that's kind of fun,
like physical like comedy,
like physical acting, like all that.
I heard you went to mime school as well.
- I worked with a mime.
- What, did you get out of the box, or?
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I'm here.
- [Kelly] You made it.
- I made it.
His license plate, he's
an incredible instructor.
His name's Lorin Salm over in LA.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I knew I was in the right place
'cause his license plate
just said SPEECHLESS.
- Oh my God.
(audience laughing)
- And I was like, "Yeah,
this is probably it."
But we worked on movement
coaching and all that
for about two to three
months, and then I showed up,
and I just wanted to help Kathryn out.
She carries so much of
the weight of the movie,
that I was like, "I gotta do something.
I gotta do something if I'm
gonna help her out here."
- Yeah, yeah, it was weird.
It's weird to read a script
and realize that you talk the whole time.
- Yeah.
- It's a little daunting, you know?
But Diablo Cody wrote
the best script ever,
and Zelda Williams, our
director, she was so,
it was like the first time
I worked with a director
where she really had this open dialogue
and communication to just talk to me
about everything from the
hair, I really wanted a wig,
it was a great wig, the
makeup, the wardrobe.
So it was like I didn't do it alone,
and I couldn't have done it without Cole.
Before we filmed, I saw him around,
I'm like, "Are you sure we can do this?"
And he's like, "We can
do this, I got you."
And it was really fun.
- Oh, that's cool.
That's fun to do with friends too.
- Yeah, it felt like friends.
It didn't, like it's weird
that you guys are gonna
watch the movie now,
'cause it just feels like, I don't know,
it's like you do a movie like this,
and it doesn't feel like
anyone's ever gonna see it.
You know when you're young and you perform
for your parents, like after
like with your best friend,
you come up with a routine.
- [Kelly] Totally.
- [Kathryn] And you do it
in the living room?
- Yep.
- I feel like you're all
in my living room now.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And gonna watch this movie.
- [Kelly] That was Prince
"When Doves Cry" for me,
yeah, my dance.
- [Kathryn] Exactly.
- Yes.
- And you make your family
watch it, so that's the vibe.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- Can't say I erupted
in the spontaneous song
and dance too often as a child.
- Gonna be honest with you,
if you catch me in Lowes
or Target, I'm probably
doing it there too at 41.
(audience laughing)
I like to embarrass whoever I'm with,
just for fun, yeah?
- That's correct,
yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I'd get behind that.
- Just seems like a good time for me.
Joining us now are the director
and the writer of the film.
Everybody please welcome Zelda Williams
and Oscar winning
screenwriter, Diablo Cody.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Oh my God, you were straight up out
of the coolest '80s movie I've ever seen.
- It was slightly calculated,
the idea, you know,
to do the '80s look today,
but thank you very much, Kelly.
I'm so excited to meet you.
- Ditto, I'm such a fan,
y'all are so talented,
we're very stoked about this movie.
So where did this movie idea come from?
- I don't know why, I just
always thought, you know,
I wanted to write a movie
about a relationship
between a living girl
and a dead dude, and it-
- [Kelly] Who doesn't?
- Yeah, I mean, the idea
just kind of knocked around
in my brain for years, and then COVID hit,
and I was trapped at
home with three children
who were suddenly homeschooled,
which is probably the most
horrifying thing imaginable.
- It was hard.
- [Diablo] It was so hard.
- Yeah.
- So I thought, I have
to escape this at night.
I'm gonna write this crazy,
freaky, romantic movie.
- That's nice.
So you write about
young people like a lot,
so what were you like as a teen?
- Not as cool as I thought I was.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- That's what I'll say.
- I have not, I didn't think I was cool,
so I didn't, I was very aware.
- See, I did,
I was delusional.
- [Kelly] You did?
- [Cole] Homeschooled.
- That's the best.
What were you like in high school?
- Not much has changed,
but I was a huge nerd.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was on the tech committee.
- [Kelly] Nice, yeah.
(all laughing)
That check.
- And I was
in circus club, so-
- You were a hit, this is amazing.
(audience laughing)
Wait, what were you, you loved golf,
so that obviously kind
of ruled your world?
- Yeah, I peaked in high school for sure.
(all laughing)
It was all downhill from there.
I loved high school, but I
wasn't there that much, right?
I wasn't there.
AcaDeca-
- That's why you loved it.
- AcaDeca, I ran for class
president, never won.
I was captain of my golf team,
which was the best, total
jock, and I was a nerd.
I was in like the science academy.
I loved school, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- It was good, good time for me.
- You, homeschooled, weren't you?
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] So you were the
smartest person in your class?
- Yeah, there was only
one other competition,
and he wasn't catching up.
(all laughing)
- He wasn't?
All right, well, Zelda,
were you a horror fan?
Have you been into horror?
- Oh yeah.
I wasn't allowed to watch
it when I was really young.
I was like the kid in my
school where I was allowed
to see "Shakespeare in Love"
while everyone else was
watching the horror films.
But as I got older, I ended
up falling in love with them.
I played a monster in
a movie many years ago,
and that kind of introduced
me to loving all the makeup
and the crazy transformations.
- The art of it, yeah.
- The art of it really,
from that point on,
there was no looking back.
- Man, I'll tell you what,
the hair and makeup teams on these movies,
like they come out and
they transform people,
it's incredible. the art
department, the sets they create,
it's an incredible gift.
- Yeah.
- This is the only movie I've ever done
where the male is in the
makeup chair longer than me.
- That is beautiful.
- [Kathryn] Yeah, it was nice.
- And never happens.
- And he doesn't talk, wow.
(audience laughs)
- And he didn't talk, it
was the best date ever.
Well, I'm gonna ask Kathryn
and Cole, like horror movies,
did y'all like those growing
up, were you into those?
- Oh, huge.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Massive.
- What were like, what's
one of your favorites?
- My favorite still is John
Carpenter's "The Thing."
- [Kelly] Oh.
- I mean, to me,
I fell in love when I was a kid
with all of the practical
effects and set design,
and I became a huge monster guy.
I fell in love
with all the big "Kaiju"
monster battle movies
when I was a kid.
Zelda and I actually share
a lot of the same tastes
when it comes to monster
movies and stuff like that.
I'm a big practical effects guy.
It was one of the reason why,
you know, I read the script,
and it felt like a
no-brainer for me, truly.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No pun intended.
- Y'all are-
(all laughing)
Y'all are probably, very nicely done.
Y'all are probably too
young, but my, I think
the scariest thing I saw as a kid was,
Freddy Krueger was the
scariest thing I ever saw.
- Freddy Krueger was my guy.
- Oh my God, we're so different.
(audience laughing)
I wouldn't go near a waterbed.
- [Diablo] Oh, right.
- Because of that Johnny Depp scene.
I was like, this is,
and I was way too young
to probably be watching it,
but it terrified me, it did.
"Nightmare on Elm Street" was your jam?
- Freddy's hilarious.
(audience laughing)
Freddy's always ready with a quip right
before he slashes someone.
- He was, okay.
- He's kind of king of
the one-liners, isn't he?
- That's, yes, I think he might've been
one of my greatest
inspirations as a writer.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- One of my greatest
inspirations for nightmares.
(all laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
Like I didn't sleep
for two years.
- You were normal,
that was the point.
- I was like, "This is
scary," and probably,
my brother's like a decade older,
so I probably shouldn't
have been watching it.
Well, we've got a game about
some of those monster movies
next, which I'm gonna fail at.
Anyway, "Lisa Frankenstein"
is in theaters this Friday.
Y'all, we'll be right back.